dune is a movie with giant sand worms
mysterious witches and timothy chalamet
tripping balls in the desert there's
spaceships and spice and zendaya with
blue eyes and almost none of it is
explained even june's characters have to
watch youtube videos to understand the
story so what's going on in dune
the movie is based on a book that was
written by frank herbert in the 60s
there have been many attempts to adapt
this book to movies and tv and most of
them aren't very good
[Music]
dune has been called unfilmable because
the book is so weird and complicated the
writing is full of internal monologue
and thoughts instead of action and
dialogue the plot is layered with heaps
of secret plans and hidden motivations
its world building is richly detailed
with hundreds of words for its languages
cultures and religions june explores big
ideas about consciousness politics and
philosophy and the june sequel books get
increasingly strange and cerebral
the new movie is a pretty close
adaptation of the first half of the
first book but it still leaves out a lot
of important plot lines and details so
how does the book compare to the movie
what's the real story of june
this video has spoilers for the 2021
dune movie and for the first half of the
first book it has no big spoilers for
the next june movie or for the sequel
books but it does mention some small
lore details and quotes from the sequel
books
so dune is set thousands of years in the
future humans live on many planets
across the universe and they're ruled by
the emperor shadow iv we see the
emperor's herald in the movie but we
don't see shadow himself yet beneath the
emperor are the great houses like house
of tradies and house hakonen powerful
political dynasties who rule planets
with armies and wealth the houses meet
in a congress called the lansrad which
balances against the power of the
emperor the other big political power is
the spacing guild because the guild
controls all interstellar space flight
guild navigators use a drug called spice
that lets them see into the future which
is the only way to guide spaceships
safely across the stars
in the movie these big guild spaceships
called hayliners look like tunnels that
you can pass through to instantly reach
a distant planet you can see another
world through this ship it's like a
wormhole the later june books describe
this as folding space
the guild is secretive and mysterious
it's hinted that guild navigators have
mutated and don't look human anymore so
everyone kind of hates the guild for
being creepy extortion at space weirdos
but everyone needs them to travel
so for thousands of years the universe
has been ruled by this balance of the
emperor houses and guild they're bound
together by the great convention which
has rules banning the use of nuclear
weapons but a cheeky bit of
assassination and warfare is allowed
within limits politics in dune is a
deadly game every noble family watches
their back for assassins and tests their
food for poison
the houses rule their planets under a
strict feudal class system slavery
oppression and exploitation are common
this is an unfair unequal universe the
houses have shares in the chome company
which controls trade in the universe
it's kind of like the dutch east india
company or amazon in space chome means
money and all the houses fight for a
slice in this struggle a tiny shift in
interest rates can change the ownership
of an entire planet
science and technology is limited in
june like there are giant spaceships and
laser guns but there are strictly no
computers or robots or ai
because thousands of years in the past
people did rely on thinking machines but
then some people used those machines to
take over the world and enslave people
and it sucked so then there was a
religious crusade called the butlerian
jihad that destroyed all the computers
and banned them forever in the orange
catholic bible it is written thou shalt
not make a machine in the likeness of a
man's mind
the idea is that thinking and making our
own decisions is what makes us human
letting machines think for us makes us
less free and less conscious so that's
why the machines were destroyed ever
since humans have had to learn to think
for themselves they founded schools to
train the human mind and body to its
full potential so now there are people
called mentats human computers who can
think super logically they process data
calculate probabilities and perceive
people's motives the meant mentat thufia
hawat works as a strategic advisor to
house atreides in the books mentats take
a drug called sappho to make themselves
smarter and the drug stains their lips
red in the new movie mentats just have
tattoos on their lips instead
like the mentats the navigators of the
spacing guild have trained their brains
to calculate the mathematics of space
flight and the other important school is
the bene jesuit an ancient mystical
order of women with highly trained minds
and bodies their practice is influenced
by zen buddhism with meditation and
contemplation to achieve inner balance
bene jesuit can precisely control all
their muscles and nerves even their
body's biochemistry and their
reproductive systems they have powerful
memories and perception they can read
people's feelings through their words
and body language they can control
people with their voice they can fight
in the weirding way they're basically
ninja nuns
the bene jesuit are named after the
jesuits a real world catholic order like
the jesuits the bene jesuit do
missionary work in distant places and
they have political ambitions the bene
jesuit work with the emperor and houses
and they say they live to serve but the
beni jesuit also have their own plans
for centuries these witches have
manipulated the universe from the
shadows
so dune is about a galactic empire with
medieval politics it's a sci-fi future
that rejects technology and instead
focuses on the power of the human mind
the author of dune frank herbert was
fascinated with thinking and learning
and language how we can expand our
consciousness to better see the universe
sometimes with the help of psychedelics
characters in june are constantly
getting high expanding their minds and
arguing about philosophy like college
undergrads so dune is basically like
game of thrones in space on drugs and
the most important drug is spice
because spice not only makes space
flight possible and can give visions of
the future spice also makes people live
longer extending lifespans by decades
many people are addicted to the spice
and if they stop taking it they'll die
it's an addictive psychic mind-expanding
life-extending spaceship-flying drug and
it tastes like cinnamon so naturally
spice is the most valuable substance in
the universe and spice only comes from
one place the desert planet arrakis also
called dune
onorakis a giant sand worms whose life
cycle makes spice humans harvest the
spice and sell it so whoever controls
arrakis becomes rich the conflicts for
resources in the deserts of arrakis are
comparable to conflicts for oil in the
middle east for the last 80 years
arrakis was ruled by the brutal house
harkenen led by the baron vladimir the
harkonnens come from the planet giadi
prime the oil-soaked blood-soaked
hellhole of the imperium the movie
imagines this planet as being totally
industrialized exploited and polluted
until nature is gone and smog blackens
the skies the harkonnens exploit their
people too they have slave laborers sex
slaves and gladiator slaves to kill for
sport the harkenins use and consume
everything to feed their endless
appetites for power and pleasure the
harkonnens are a mouth that swallows all
the baron vladimir is a ruthless
political schemer who constantly
indulges his desires for food and sex
he's too fat to support his own weight
so he uses suspensor technology which
lets him levitate to rule arrakis the
baron installed his nephew rabban who is
called the beast for his brutality
rabban is not known for his intelligence
the baron thinks of rabban as a
muscle-minded tank brain
the harkonnens are advised by pita
devries a mentat assassin who loves
torture and poison
pita is addicted to spice and this
expensive habit forces him to stay loyal
to the baron the baron uses people's
weaknesses to control them
in the movie the harkenings have a
freaky human spider thing as a pet which
is not in the books but according to
interviews it's meant to be a messed up
science experiment this was a human who
was made into a monster in the books
there is a faction called the tlaxu who
do weird biology experiments so maybe
they made this spider some fans theorize
that this spider is yui's captive wife
wanna made into a monster to torture her
but that's just horrifying speculation
and is not in the books point is the
harkenans are dicks and the spice on
arrakis made them rich but at the start
of the story the emperor orders the
hakkanens to leave and he gives control
of the planet to house atreides led by
duke lato the atreides have a reputation
for honor and integrity they protect
their people and inspire loyalty in
return the atreides are descended from
atrius and agamemnon of ancient greece
and they rule the planet kaladan a world
of oceans and jungles farming and
fishing the atreides aren't very rich
but lato is popular and influential
among the houses of the landsrad and the
emperor hates that he sees nato's
popularity as a threat so when shaddam
gives them arrakis that seems like a
good thing for the atreides but really
arrakis is a trap the emperor and the
hakonens secretly planned to destroy the
atreides with an army of sardakar
sadhakar are the emperor's elite
soldiers renowned for being brutal and
merciless they're said to be the
deadliest soldiers in the universe the
sadaka come from celusus akundus a
prison planet for the worst criminals in
the universe seleusa is a hell world
where only the strongest survive and
it's this harsh environment that makes
the sardocar so powerful the emperor
doesn't want the other houses to know
that he's attacking the atreides so in
the book his sadhaka are disguised in
haakonen uniforms he and the harkonnens
want the atreides to die in the dark
the story begins with paul atreides son
of the duke lato and lady jessica paul
is just 15 years old in the book and as
the heir to house atreides there's a lot
of pressure on him he has no friends his
own age because of the dangers of
assassination he's highly trained in
politics and in combat and in the book
he's trained as a mentat to have a
powerful logical mind like through fear
jessica trains paul in the way of the
bene jesuit to focus his mind and body
his perception and memory and to use the
power of the voice to control people
give me the water
it might seem unrealistic to control
someone with your voice but author frank
herbert said we do it all the time like
it's easy to make someone angry with an
insult or happy with a compliment and
with practice you can control people in
more subtle and powerful ways like
politicians and advertisers do you've
just got to know your audience use the
right words and tone
like and subscribe to alt shift x
so paul is young but he's a politician
and a warrior with a powerful highly
trained mind
lato visits the grave of his father the
old duke the old duke used to fight
bulls for sport as a matador until he
was killed by a bull in the ring the
atreides family keep the head of this
bull with the old duke's blood still
preserved on its horns so the bullhead
represents facing danger putting
yourself at risk just like lato is
putting himself in danger by coming to
arrakis lato knows that the emperor and
the harkonnens plan to attack him but he
takes the risk anyway because he
believes he can win
lato plans to use the desert power of
arrakis by making an alliance with the
fremen the local desert people in the
book lato believes that the fremen will
be great soldiers specifically because
they live in the harsh environment of
arrakis just like the sardakar are
powerful because of the harshness of
seleucid secundus author frank herbert
was very interested in how environments
affect people and how people affect
their environment
so lato bets everything on this plan to
make the fremen into his army to beat
the sardakar
in the movie paul says he doesn't want
to exploit or oppress the freeman like
the harkonnens did but in the book the
atreides don't care about the fremen
like that their goal is to exploit the
foreign the atreides may seem like
heroic good guys like house stark in
space but throughout the book they use
immoral manipulative strategies and were
invited to question their morality in
the movie chaney asks who will our next
oppressors be
in the movie paul complains that he
doesn't get to take risks and have
adventures he questions whether he even
wants to be a duke and to lead the
atreides lato is understanding and says
he loves paul no matter what it's a
touching moment of unconditional love
between father and son but in the book
we don't see anything like this the
atreides are more formal and distant and
serious in the book and paul does not
question his duty to their house the
atreides in the book are an ancient
dynasty in a deadly planetary conflict
and they are not [ __ ] around
while the movie humanizes the atreides
and makes them feel more like a normal
relatable family
the atreides get a visit from gaius
helen mahayam gaius is a reverent mother
a special high-ranking bene jesuit who
has expanded her mind using drugs
reverend mothers have access to the
memories of their ancestors and of other
reverent mothers gaius was jessica's
teacher back at the bene jesuit school
and now she's the personal truth-sayer
of the emperor he uses her for her
ability to detect lies
so gaius is a powerful important person
and she has complicated loyalties to the
emperor and to jessica and to the bene
jesuit
gaius gives paul a test paul puts his
hand in a box that causes terrible pain
but if he moves his hand gaius will kill
him with a needle called the gomjabar so
this is a test of self-control someone
without self-control like an animal will
instinctively move away from the pain
and will die to survive you have to
withstand the pain control your body and
mind master your fear and your instincts
the bene jesuit believe that this
ability to act consciously and to choose
to think long term not just in the
moment is what separates humans from
animals they give this test to everyone
they train so that only responsible
conscious humans gain their power so
anyone who fails this test they kill
before the test we see the atreides
bullhead because like the old duke with
the bull and later with arrakis paul
faces deadly danger in this test
when jessica was trained as a bene
jesuit she took this test too so she
knows the pain paul is feeling and is
terrified he might die to calm herself
she recites the litany against fear fear
is the mind killer but the fear will
pass through me and i will remain the
bene jesuit train to calm their emotions
and focus their mind and jessica's
training helps paul pass this test
paul has self-control he is human so he
withstands the pain and lives
in the movie he also has fiery visions
of the upcoming harkonnen attack
then we learn about the bene jesuit's
secret plan
for thousands of years the bene jesuit
have manipulated the genetic lines of
noble families like the atreides they
breed certain people with other people
often by marriage to bene jesuits like
jessica even the emperor has a bene
jesuit wife controlling his reproduction
they select and combine certain genes
trying to produce a superhuman called
the quizatz hadarac
this chosen one will be able to see into
the future and the past better than any
bene jesuit because reverend mothers
like gaius can only access the memories
of their female ancestors the quizatz
had iraq will access all memories he'll
be a male reverend mother whose powerful
mind will guide humanity
the name quizat's hadarak is borrowed
from a real hebrew term meaning to
shorten the way between two places
so the bene jesuit want to create the
chosen one but jessica has messed with
their plan because the bene jesuit
wanted jessica to have a daughter not a
son that daughter was going to marry a
haakonen and their child would have been
the quizatz had iraq but jessica with
her bene jesuit body control chose to
have a son paul instead because later
wanted a son and jessica wanted to make
him happy she chose her family over her
duty to the bene jesuit jessica hopes
that paul will be the quizats had iraq
instead but gaius is doubtful their
ancient plan is now uncertain
so paul might be the chosen one and he's
not happy about it it feels weird and
gross that he's the product of the bene
jesuits human breeding program their
manipulative eugenic plan
in the book he feels an offense against
his instinct for rightness he questions
gaius thinks she's a fatuous old witch
full of meaningless platitudes in other
sci-fi stories the hero's magical
mentors are good and wise and pure like
obi-wan and gandalf the white but gaius
is a creepy witch in a black robe who
works for the emperor who's trying to
kill paul's dad the bene jesuit are a
shadowy political cult and their plan to
artificially create the chosen one seems
sinister and dark
in the book paul feels that he is
infected with a terrible purpose that he
doesn't understand so what is paul's
destiny and is it really a good thing
dune is about questioning the whole idea
of heroes religions politicians
predictions and plans it's about the
danger of anything that reduces our
ability to think for ourselves
one of paul's teachers is gurney hallick
gurney is a legendary fighter like one
of the best in the universe he's also a
musician and a poet a minstrel warrior
who plays an instrument called a
ballastet they did film a ballasted
scene for the movie but it was cut
in the book gurney often sings and
quotes poetry and wise scripture and
dirty lyrics his charming words and
music help the atreides win allies and
influence people
gurney is described as an ugly lump of a
man he's got a big red scar across his
face and a burning hatred for the
harkonnens cause in the book gurney was
once a slave of the harkonnens the beast
rabban killed gurney's family and gave
him his scar so gurney wants revenge
gurney says in the movie that the
hakkenans are so brutal that they're not
human the harkonnens are often described
as animals or beasts ruled by their
impulses which contrasts with the idea
of humans with conscious self-control
paul and gurney train at fighting using
shields
shields
are force fields that can stop any
fast-moving object but a slow blade can
get through guns and explosives are
useless against shields so that's why
soldiers in dune fight with swords and
knives instead
the trick to shield fighting is to
outsmart outmaneuver and distract your
opponent so you can kill with a sneaky
slow attack
so like everything in dune even the
sword fights are smart and strategic
like a chess game
paul says that he's not in the mood for
fighting but gurney says you must always
be ready no matter how you feel so just
like with the gomja bar test this is
about self-control to survive the deadly
blade you must master your emotions your
body and mind
one of paul's other teachers is duncan
idaho who is also a legendary fighter
he's a swordmaster of the genas a
military genius he's super hot and is
fiercely loyal to the atreides duncan is
a close friend to paul almost like a big
brother in the movie paul tells duncan
about the dreams he's been having of the
future of this fremen girl chaney and of
duncan dying on arrakis
these prescient visions are part of
paul's power as the potential quizats
had iraq in the movie duncan tells paul
not to focus too much on dreams he says
everything important happens when we're
awake cause june is about the power of
thoughts and visions but it also warns
us not to get too sucked into our own
minds our assumptions and plans the
mystery of life isn't a problem to solve
but a reality to experience
the deepest truths and the joy and
meaning in life come from living in the
present
before he leaves his homeworld paul
walks a kaladan beach calidan is a
planet of water to contrast the harsh
dry deserts of arrakis calidan is
beautiful plentiful a paradise but the
book says that the comforts of kaladan
made the atreides go soft life was too
easy they got undisciplined dune says
that people need adversity and hard
times in order to grow and achieve our
potential and arrakis is the ultimate
challenge it's a test like the gomja bar
like the bull now paul goes into the
fire will arrakis forge him stronger
like the fremen or will paul burn
the atreides arrive on arrakis and this
guy blasts a bagpipe solo
when the people of arrakis see paul and
jessica they shout lissan al-gayeb which
means the voice from the outer world
because there's a prophecy on arrakis
that there will come a leader the child
of a bene jesuit who will lead arrakis
to freedom paul and jessica seem to fit
this prophecy but thing is this prophecy
is a lie it was made up by the bene
jesuit the bene jesuit have a whole
system for this called the missionary
protectiva for thousands of years they
have spread specific religious ideas or
infectious superstitions all over the
universe particular religious signs and
sayings are planted in local cultures so
if a bene jesuit is ever on one of these
planets they can use those signs and
sayings to gain power over people june
author frank herbert said this was
inspired by missionaries in the real
world who use religion to manipulate and
exploit other cultures so the people of
arrakis hope that paul and jessica are
the chosen ones who will free them but
really the lissan al-gaib prophecy is a
cynical tool used by the bernie jesuret
to control people
the atreides move into their new home in
the city of hurricane and jessica hires
a friend woman called mapes to be a
housekeeper not all the people of arakas
are fremen like the people of the cities
and the villages aren't fremen the
fremen are their own specific culture
who live out in the desert a renegade
will of the sand people who live outside
the control of the imperium fremen all
have blue eyes because their environment
is saturated with spice and spice is
colored blue in the books
fremen have a reputation for being
fierce and dangerous they compose poems
to their knives
the harkonnens and the emperor see the
fremen as scum and barbarians who aren't
worth considering they think that there
are only a few thousand fremen living on
the edge of the desert but the atreides
think there could be lots more fremen
and that they could be more powerful
than they seem
so the fremen are a mystery at the start
of the book and we gradually learn more
about them
mapes has the honorary title shadow
which means well dipper because water is
super important in the fremen desert
culture
and mapes isn't just here for a job
interview she came to test jessica to
see if she really fits the prophecy of
the lissan al-ghaib
so mapes shows jessica a chris knife a
blade made from the tooth of a sand worm
and she asks jessica what is the meaning
of this knife jessica says it's a maker
and mabes gets all excited because the
fremen call sandworms makers so this
seems to show that jessica must know the
secrets of frame and religion and she
and paul must be the lisan al-ghaib but
thing is in the book jessica is
bullshitting mapes jessica doesn't know
the religious meaning of the kris knife
she was gonna say that the knife is a
maker of death to mean it's just a
weapon but mapes interrupted jessica
once she heard what she wanted to hear
jessica plays along and acts like she
knows all this fremen religious stuff
using signs and sayings from the
missionary protactiva but inside jessica
knows this is a sham
jessica exploits mapes's religion to
manipulate her and win her loyalty dune
is about the danger of religion how it
can warp our thinking and control us
but this isn't just about the atreides
using the fremen in the book after
jessica leaves mapes says to herself
that jessica is the one poor thing
mapes pities jessica and knows things
about her future it's hinted that just
as the atreides use the fremen the
fremen may be using the atreides for
their own goals
paul is attacked by a hunter seeker a
weapon of assassination it's like a
flying remote controlled needle a
ravening sliver of metal that can burrow
into flesh to strike the heart
the hunter seeker is controlled remotely
by a hearken an assassin the camera on
the seeker is bad so it relies on motion
to find its target so to survive paul
has to stand perfectly still while the
deadly needle points at his face
so this is just like the gomja bar test
paul faces a deadly needle and to
survive he has to stay still mastering
his fear and his body
meanwhile in the book jessica explores
her new home and she finds a mysterious
door locked with a palm reader which is
a lock that only opens to the shape of a
particular person's hand so jessica
picks the lock by subtly changing the
shape of her own palm using her bene
jesuit muscle control in other sci-fi
stories characters might use hacking or
magic or raw strength to break a lock
but june is about the power of the mind
so that's how jessica opens the door
inside jessica finds a conservatory a
place full of lush plants and water on
this dry desert world it's beautiful but
it's a terrible waste this much water
could sustain a thousand lives on
arrakis but instead it's used for the
pleasure of the rich and powerful
in the movie there's a scene with these
palm trees which are also a waste of
precious water the gardener says that
the waste is okay because the trees are
sacred but in the books these trees
aren't sacred the people of arakas look
on these trees with envy and hate for
the waste of water but the movie takes
away that moral complication and instead
emphasizes the mystical connection
between arrakis's people and its
environment anyway in the conservatory
jessica finds a hidden message from
another bene jesuit a message so secret
that it's written on a leaf in braille
and it warns her that there's a traitor
among the atreides working for the
hakonens
in the book thufia also gets a message
warning of the traitor this message was
planted by the hakonens and they
deliberately trick thufia into thinking
that jessica is the traitor the
harkenans divide the atreides in the
book turn them against each other to
distract from the real traitor dr yui
who is working for the harkonnens when
thufia tells lato this lato doesn't
believe that his beloved jessica is
plotting against him but he decides to
pretend that he thinks jessica is the
traitor to make the hakonens think they
tricked him while he looks for the real
traitor so the plot quickly gets
complicated in the book june is full of
these plans within plans the story is a
chess game where only the best minds
survive
and there's a sense from the start of
the book that lato is doomed to fail
that he's a man snared by destiny caught
in an inescapable trap lato has death
thoughts thinking about how he'll die
and paul is shocked to see this
vulnerability in his father paul sees
that lato makes mistakes and he realizes
that his dad won't be around forever
part of paul growing up and becoming a
man is seeing the flaws and the
mortality in his father
the atreides takeover of arrakis doesn't
go well the harkenings left behind
broken equipment so the atreides can't
harvest much spice yet and they're still
expecting an attack from the emperor's
sadaka and the harkonnens lato's great
hope is the freyman
lato sent duncan to try to make an
alliance with the fremen originally the
june movie started with a scene of
duncan landing on arrakis so duncan
meets the fremen and he learns that the
fremen live in caves called ceaches
there are millions of fremen living deep
in the desert way more than the
harkonnens and the emperor realize the
fremen are also technologically advanced
manufacturing devices to help them
survive in the desert
duncan also learns that the framing are
deadly in combat
so the harkonnens and the emperor are
too arrogant and prejudiced to see the
potential of the fremen but the atreides
are open-minded and willing to learn
which opens up the possibility of
victory
so the atreides meet stilgar the leader
of a freman siege the book emphasizes
stilgar's aura of power and his
commanding voice he's an impressive
figure unlike the arrogant harkenans
lato shows respect for stilger and his
people so stilga shows respect for lato
by spitting on the table because in
fremont desert culture giving moisture
from the body is a sign of respect
in the book duncan helped the fremen
fight some harkonnens so stilga invites
duncan to join his fremen while also
serving lato representing an alliance
between stilgar and the atreides stilgar
gives duncan a criss knife the sacred
maker's blade and it's mentioned that
the harkenings are offering a huge
bounty to anyone who can bring them a
chris knife because anyone who has a
kris knife and has spice blue eyes would
appear to be a fremen they could
infiltrate any siege and in the book the
harkening mentat pita has blue eyes
because of his spice addiction so it
seems that the harkonnens want a chris
knife so that pieta can infiltrate the
fremen so that he can kill the atreides
if the atreides hide with the fremen so
this is another deadly subplot hidden
within the story
but the meeting with stillgar goes well
and there's hope for a larger alliance
between the atreides and the freemen the
atreides meet liet kynes kynes is an
ecologist or planetologist working for
the emperor to study the environment of
arrakis she's also the judge of the
change meaning it's her job to make sure
everyone follows the rules when the
harkenings leave arrakis and the
atreides take over but secretly the
emperor has ordered kines to help betray
the atreides and to let the harkenans
attack them but kines's loyalties are
even more complicated than that in the
book liet kines is a man kinzer's father
was pardo kines the previous imperial
ecologist and liet kinza's mother was a
ferment woman so liet keines was raised
as a fremen on arrakis liet kyans also
married a freman and they had a child
called chaney so chaney is kines's
daughter in the movie as well as in the
book so kynes works for the emperor but
kynes is really loyal to the fremen
kines leads the fremen under the name
liet
in the book lyat and kines seem to be
two different people at first the
atreides think the mysterious lieet
might be the name of a fremen god it's
only later that we find out that lyette
the fremen leader and kinds of the
planetologists are the same person
so there are two sides to kyan's
identity imperial and fremen outsider
and native scientist and leader
kinds gives the atreides still suits
still suits are special outfits for the
desert that cool the body and stop it
from losing moisture all of your sweat
pee and poop is captured by the suit and
reprocessed back into drinking water
because without a still suit in the
desert's heat you'll soon lose your
moisture and die
the book goes into lots of detail about
all the different technologies people
use to adapt to arrakis's environment
kinds shows the atreides how to wear the
still suits properly it's a difficult
technical thing for someone who's never
used one before but paul somehow already
knows how to wear a still suit properly
and that shocks kinds because it fits
part of the prophecy of the lisan
al-qaeda he shall know your ways as
though born to them paul's personality
and his words and his ability to see the
truth also fit the prophecy
in the book kinds thinks of himself as a
rational skeptical scientist who doesn't
believe in superstitions but paul does
fit the prophecy so it seems like there
might be some truth in the prophecy
mixed in with the bene jesuit's
manipulations
the atreides fly out to the desert to
learn about spice harvesting these
flying machines are called ornithopters
which is a real word for flying machines
with flapping wings the book describes
thopters as looking like birds with
feathered wings
harvester machines extract spice from
the sand using centrifuges in the book
they look like giant beetles with snouts
and leg-like tracks the movie uses a
simple industrial look for its
technology but the books have a more
fantastical and colorful 60s sci-fi vibe
the vibrations from spice harvesting
always attract sand worms so when a worm
comes harvesters are flown to safety by
a carryall but this time the carry-all
breaks in the book it doesn't turn up at
all because of harkenan's sabotage so
duke lato heroically risks his life to
save the workers from the sand worm this
shows that lato genuinely cares about
protecting people human life matters
more to him than money and that's what
makes him different to the harkonnens
but lato isn't totally selfless he is a
politician so in the book he and gurney
give the workers a bonus payment and he
says it's for public relations to make
people like lato
kynes points out that lato floods
arrakis with propaganda telling people
to love the good duke and lato admits
that propaganda is a big part of why his
men are so loyal his image as a heroic
leader is partly an act a mask for
political advantage
so the atreides do show some real
heroism but that image is partly a
cynical tool that they use to control
people
in the book the atreides host a dinner
party with important people on arrakis
businessmen politicians smugglers it
gives the sense of a larger world on
arrakis this is a planet with lots of
different players with their own plans
and motivations
when the harkonnens were in charge here
they had a custom where they
deliberately waste water dumping it onto
towels on the ground then allowing poor
people to beg for drops of moisture it
was cruel and demeaning so plato stops
this custom and gives beggars water
instead and jessica declares that the
conservatory that wastes so much water
will now be held in trust for all the
people of arakas
so again the atreides do good with
gestures of respect and generosity lato
says that he's gonna change things on
arrakis but does he really meaningfully
make things better like sure he gives
water to a few beggars but he does
nothing to change this fundamentally
unfair political system
and right after banning the water custom
lato just does a different water wasting
ritual instead so maybe these gestures
are just more propaganda to make the
atreides look good dune is critical of
politicians who appear liberal and
progressive but are really just
aristocrats protecting their own power
author frank herbert said that the
atreides are admirable but they act with
the same arrogance towards common folk
as do their enemies
while the atreides act honest and
honorable in public they do some sneaky
[ __ ] on the down-low like the
atreides forge signatures to take
property and evict the families of
people who worked for the harknets the
atreides use thufia who is a master of
assassins whose ruthless methods bring
death and deceit wherever he goes and
lato's whole plan here is to exploit the
fremen as his army and exploit the land
for spice lato says that he makes moral
compromises for political gain he says
that the honorable atreides banner could
come to mean many evil things
so the atreides are more moral than the
brutal hakonens but their power is still
fundamentally based on coercion and
force
like this dinner party is fancy and
glamorous but it's also very tense
people are nervous about getting
poisoned so inside a chandelier there's
a hidden device that detects poison the
atreides use secret hand signals to
ready their soldiers during dinner
this shows the fakeness of political
power behind the formality and glamour
there is always the deadly threat of
violence
some of the most powerful people at the
party are those who control water on
arrakis because everyone needs water to
live and on this planet there's barely
any of it paul has to explain to someone
what drowning is and what boats are
because there isn't enough water on
arrakis for anyone to ever drown or use
a boat so alongside spice water is a
precious resource here author frank
herbert said the value of water on
arrakis is equivalent to oil and the way
this natural resource shapes politics
and culture shows the overarching
constant importance of the environment
no one is completely separated from
natural forces like water scarcity not
the poor begging for drops of moisture
nor the politicians who compete to
control it one of the most important
characters in june is the planet itself
so everyone eats fine food and makes
small talk and secretly plots to destroy
each other jessica realizes that a
spacing guild guy is working with the
harkonnens and we learn that the
hawkenans are smuggling laseguns to
arrakis women try to seduce paul a water
seller bickers with kinds and we get a
sense of mysterious power from kinds
connected to kansas relationship with
the fremen the atreides talk about
changing the environment of arrakis to
give it more water and plants and kynes
acts weird and secretive about whether
this is possible and this whole time
lato is pretending to suspect jessica as
a traitor and he's super stressed about
it so at this party the plots thicken
the tension rises and there's a growing
sense of danger to the atreides all
night the bull head looms above with a
tradies blood on its horns
later in the book duncan gets drunk he's
stressed and homesick on this dangerous
alien world so he gets wasted and
complains and he reveals to jessica that
thufia thinks she's a traitor so jessica
finally understands why lato has been
acting weird and distant with her
pretending to suspect her and so she
goes and confronts the fear she tells
the fear that she's not a traitor and
she criticizes thufia's mentat logic
saying he is good at analyzing the world
around him but he fails to analyze his
own thoughts and feelings she says he's
biased against her for being a bene
jesuit and that he's jealous of her
closeness with lato she brags about her
power and uses her voice on thufia
thufia gets angry too and he considers
killing jessica this infighting is
exactly what the harkonnens want and
jessica realizes this but she and thufia
failed to work together because of their
emotions jessica and thuffy are a bene
jesuit and a mentat both highly trained
intelligent superhumans but no matter
how smart you are everyone has human
weaknesses pride jealousy anger fear
biases their emotions overwhelm their
rational minds and so jessica and thufia
fail to find the real traitor and fail
to save their family
lato finds out about this fight between
jessica and thufia and he feels bad
about acting suspicious of the woman he
loves he regrets that he never married
jessica because technically jessica is
lato's concubine not his wife lato stays
unmarried because it's politically
useful to seem like he's available for a
marriage alliance but really he loves
jessica and wouldn't marry anyone else
lato goes to tell jessica the truth and
to apologise about pretending to suspect
her but tragically before he can tell
her lato is attacked by the real traitor
yui
so yui is the doctor for the atreides
family and in the book the atreides
think that it's impossible for him to be
a traitor because yui is a suk school
doctor with imperial conditioning
imperial conditioning is a kind of
mental training that supposedly makes it
impossible for a sook doctor to kill or
betray their masters this diamond tattoo
on yui's forehead is the mark of a sook
doctor but the harkenans broke yui's
conditioning they captured yui's wife
wanna and they tortured her to blackmail
yui into obeying them so yui betrays the
atreides but he does it for a good
reason to protect his wife yui doesn't
want to hurt the atreides he loves them
so throughout the book yui feels
conflicted guilty and stressed keeping
his secret
yui thinks that after betraying lato
he'll be remembered by history as a
terrible villain and he's right each
chapter of the june book starts with a
quote or excerpt from an in-universe
history book written years after the
events of the story they give us
glimpses of how future historians think
about these characters and in these
books yui is remembered as a name black
in treachery a child's history says a
million deaths were not enough for yui
so this shows how history doesn't
capture the full story of people's lives
yui is a traitor but he's not some
one-dimensional villain he's a complex
layered character with his own feelings
and perspective
earlier in the book yui gives paul an
orange catholic bible he thinks he gives
paul the gift of religion before he
betrays paul so you thinks paul will go
where you cannot go meaning that paul
will go to heaven but ue thinks himself
damned to hell
yui talks with jessica which is very
dangerous for yui because as a bene
jesuit jessica can read people's
feelings and detect lies so yui has to
carefully control his words and emotions
to hide that he's a traitor he masks his
secret by expressing his real grief for
his wife wanna jessica opens up too and
they really connect emotionally so much
that yui almost decides to tell jessica
the truth that he's working for the
harkonnens jessica sees that yui is
hiding something from her but she
decides not to investigate because yui
is such a good friend and she feels she
should trust him so this tragic
heartfelt scene makes us feel sorry for
yui before his betrayal
yui kills mapes he hits lato with a
paralyzing dart he gives paul and
jessica sleeping drugs so they can be
captured and yui turns off the atreides
house shields so the harkinans and
sardakar can attack
but yui also betrays the hakonens he
installs a fake tooth into lato's mouth
a weapon filled with poison gas he tells
lato to use it to kill the baron to get
revenge for the torture of his wife
so the hakonens and sadaka attack and
the atreides are shocked by how many
soldiers arrive the baron paid the
spacing guild a huge amount of money for
troop transport like 60 years worth of
arrakis entire income the baron has been
planning this for a long time and he
takes no chances to crush the atreides
in the movie the harkenans use these
slow bombs which decelerate so they can
penetrate shields while in the book the
harkenings use old-fashioned explosive
artillery against atreides men hiding in
caves it's a surprise secret weapon to
use such ancient technology the
harkenings kill or scatter all atreides
on the planet and they stamp out
resistance by cutting up the desert with
laseguns they want total extermination
of the atreides
in the book there's a scene where the
baron and piter have jessica captive the
baron had promised to give jessica to
piter as his prisoner or slave which is
terrifying because paita is a sadistic
torturer and killer pita is a twisted
mentat the baron and the tlalaksu have
corrupted him made him an animal with
violent selfish desires and this makes
spite of a less rational and less
effective thinker like the baron
convinces python not to take jessica and
instead promises him control of arrakis
and jessica sees that the baron is lying
and manipulating piper but with his
twisted mentat mind piter doesn't see
this
and the baron fails to see how dangerous
pieter is to him so the baron and piter
are both smart dangerous people and this
is their moment of victory but jessica
sees that they're kind of incompetent
the harkonnen's minds are so clouded and
distracted by their emotions and their
arrogance and greed they're not focused
and disciplined like jessica and paul's
powerful human minds
the baron wants lato atreides and all
his family dead the emperor and the bene
jesuit are okay with lato dying but they
don't want jessica and paul killed as
well because jessica and paul are
important to the bene jesuit breeding
plan and under the rules of warfare in
dune murdering entire noble families is
generally frowned upon so the baron
can't kill jessica and paul directly
because the truthsayer gaius could
interrogate him and learn the truth so
instead the baron tries to kill jessica
and paul indirectly he suggests that
piter may choose to dump jessica and
paul in the desert so that the desert
will kill them so then the baron can say
truthfully that he didn't kill jessica
and paul the baron twists the truth with
word trickery dune explores how words
and language can be deceptive and can
limit our thinking so some of the most
talkative characters in june are the bad
guys like in the new movie the baron
doesn't say much but in the book the
baron never shuts up he's constantly
indulging in theatrical
self-aggrandizing speeches while the
heroic atreides are men of few words in
dune the deepest truths are not
expressed with words but must be
experienced first hand
so paul and jessica are sent to the
desert to die
one of the guards is deaf and jessica is
gagged so she can't use her voice power
to control the man paul is not as good
at the voice as jessica is but he
manages to command the men to un-gag
jessica so she can use her voice to
control and kill them
in the movie paul does some cute
footwork to trip a guy while in the book
paul kicks the dude so hard that his
heart stops
we see yui's diamond symbol here on the
thopter because yui has pulled some
strings to help paul and jessica escape
he hides a fremen desert survival kit in
the thopter and he arranges for duncan
to find them in the desert so yui is
forced to betray the atreides but he
also does everything he can to help save
paul and jessica
and then yui faces the baron the deal
was that yui would help the baron defeat
the atreides and then the baron would
free yui's wife wanna let him join her
but the baron just kills yui so that he
and wanna can join each other in death
again the baron twists the truth with
word trickery
so in the movie it seems like yui just
failed the baron beat him but in the
book it's different because yui never
really believed that the baron would
give his wife back he thought she was
probably already dead but he needed to
know for certain that one is free from
her suffering wanna was a bene jesuit
and she taught yui some truth sense
skills so by facing the baron in person
and reading his face yui learns that yes
wanna is definitely dead she's free from
hearken and torture and with that
knowledge yui can die satisfied yui also
succeeds in helping paul and jessica
escape and he gives lato the poisoned
tooth to attack the baron yui says that
lato was gonna die anyway with the
emperor and the harkonnens against him
so at least yui gives lato a chance to
bring the baron down with him
so yui feels that he succeeded he
outsmarted the baron and helped the
atreides so with his final breath huey
is defiant and triumphant
history remembers yui as an evil villain
but in a way his death is a heroic
self-sacrifice dying for his wanna and
for the atreides
the baron faces lato helpless before him
he's wanted this for a long time house
honkin and house atreides have hated
each other for 10 000 years ever since
an atreides banished a hakonen for
cowardice after a battle now the baron
can finally destroy his ancient enemies
but in the book the baron's victory
feels sour he's disturbed by yui's
defiance and he finds out that paul and
jessica have escaped the baron feels
frustrated and uncertain so he seeks
comfort in food dune is about the
importance of self-control mastering
your mind and body so the villain the
baron is someone who's totally
controlled by his body's desires the
baron constantly eats he is always
hungry and thirsty he has evil sexual
desires in the book the baron drugs and
rapes slave boys
the baron is so ruled by his urges that
he can't even control the movements of
his body the baron's hands are
constantly touching and fiddling
compulsively the baron is a beast ruled
by his hunger and his lust he is the
opposite of the bene jesuit ideal of
human self-control
but while the baron can't control
himself he does control others he treats
people like objects to be used and
exploited he uses yui he uses rabban he
plans to kill pieter when he outlives
his usefulness he thinks of the people
of arrakis as slaves as no more than a
labour pool he thinks of his men and of
his enemies as bees and rabbits or as
sheep and chickens and of himself as a
carnivore
the baron reduces people to animals and
objects he dehumanizes everyone around
him and that's what makes him the
ultimate evil in a story about the human
spirit
in lato's last moments he remembers
happy days with his family on kaladan
his last thought is the day the flesh
shapes and the flesh the day shapes
which suggests that our experiences and
environment make us who we are and that
we make our experiences and our
environment in return lato feels
interconnected with the universe when he
dies so there's a legend that in the
instant he died a meteor streaked
through the sky on kaladan
laeto uses his poison tooth to try to
kill the baron the gas kills pita but
the baron survives because he has his
shield on in the movie he's still hurt
by the gas so he needs to have a medical
black goo bath at a day spa to recover
the black goo isn't in the book but it
is in the old david lynch dune movie so
maybe it's a reference to that or it
could be a reference to this shot in
apocalypse now or maybe it's a reference
to the couch and it's always sunny who
knows
paul and jessica take shelter in a still
tent and paul's consciousness expands
the effects of the spice of his training
of the shock of his father's death it
all comes together to unlock a powerful
new awareness his mind now perceives
every detail of the world around him he
processes and computes vast data like a
mentat but more
paul has visions of the future not just
in dreams but in waking awareness the
veil is ripped away to reveal naked time
he doesn't see just one certain future
he sees many different possibilities
branching paths ever-changing and
undulating like ocean waves he doesn't
see everything much of the future is
hidden from him but paul sees many
things like that jessica is pregnant and
that her daughter will be saint aliyah
of the knife
he sees that he and jessica will stay on
arrakis and that their eyes will turn
blue from exposure to spice
jessica thinks that paul must be the
quizatz hadorak of the bene jesuit plan
but paul says that he's something else
something unexpected a seed and he again
feels his sense of terrible purpose
paul sees a future of religious war of
fanatical legions spreading violence
across the universe in the atreides name
with him as their messianic leader
the book calls this war a jihad or
crusade and connects it to a primordial
human need to spread our genes across
the universe to evolve and diversify the
species through chaos and upheaval it's
war as a collective orgasm
paul wants to prevent this terrible
violent future and in the book he's
horrified by how his own mind has
changed all this knowledge and cold
logic separates paul from his emotions
his father is dead and he wants to
grieve but he feels nothing
his transcendence takes away some of his
humanity paul feels that he's a monster
and a freak and he blames jessica
because jessica's training is part of
what caused this change in him jessica
suddenly feels afraid of this powerful
mind that she helped create
in the book paul considers joining the
spacing guild because they would
appreciate his powerful prescient mind
but he decides not to because those guys
are weird and gross instead he says he
and jessica will join the fremen and
they will call him muad deeb the one who
points the way
muadeeb is the name of this kangaroo
mouse which paul sees in the movie a
couple times
this mouse is well adapted to survive in
the deserts of arrakis and the mouse has
a special meaning in fremont mythology
because one of arrakis's two moons has
markings that look like the mullah deep
mouse so paul emerges from the womb-like
tent reborn he has transformed and
expanded his mind and he is no longer a
child but a man the new duke atreides
now at last paul can mourn his father
paul and jessica meet up with duncan and
they take refuge with kines the emperor
ordered kines to help destroy the
atreides so kines is taking a huge risk
by protecting them but kind saw lato's
heroism and leadership kinds saw that
paul fits the framing prophecies and
kinds saw that the atreides are
interested in changing arrakis's
environment
kines takes the atreides to an old
ecological station a science lab that
studies the environment of arrakis the
book explains that keynes's father pardo
taught the fremen about ecology the
systems of life climate water and
animals pardo and the fremen made a plan
to transform the environment of arrakis
to make it into a green planet full of
water and plants
after pardo died lietkinds and the
fremen have continued to change arrakis
they've been planting vegetation in the
desert feeding it moisture harvested
from the wind starting oases of life and
water to reshape the desert and they're
doing this secretly the fremen have been
bribing the spacing guild with spice to
hide from an activity from satellites
paul tells kines that he could help
transform arrakis if paul becomes
emperor of the universe with his new
consciousness and confidence paul plans
a play for the throne if paul can prove
to the other houses of the landsrad that
the emperor attacked the atreides
everyone would turn against the emperor
that's the whole point of the lands
route it limits the emperor's power to
protect the houses so paul plans to
blackmail the emperor and to marry one
of the emperor's daughters to take the
throne himself then paul could help
kines change uracus
so paul shows great confidence and
authority but in the book he also shows
humility and loyalty to kinds he says
he'd give his life for kinds showing
that atreides heroic image and so kines
becomes loyal to paul
then the sardakar attack coming to
capture or kill the atreides in the
movie the sadaka cut through a door with
a laze gun laseguns are powerful weapons
but they're also super dangerous because
if a laser beam touches a shield the
shield and the laser gun explode like a
huge nuclear explosion which kills the
lasegun user as well as their target
earlier in the book duncan leaves a
shield as a trap to blow up a bunch of
sadaka so because of that the sadaka
avoid using laseguns here because
they're scared of hitting a shield again
to give paul and jessica time to escape
duncan heroically holds off the sadaka
and is killed
just like in paul's dream earlier so
this shows that paul's visions of the
future can come true will the holy war
come true as well
kinds paul and jessica escape through a
secret exit in the book they go through
a whole maze with lights that guide the
way but then extinguish so that the
sardakar can't follow them
in the movie kines heads into the desert
and uses a device called a thumper to
attract a sand worm with these maker
hooks kaine's plans to mount and ride a
sand sandworm to travel which is one of
the great secrets of framing power but
kynes is attacked by sadaka because
kinds disobeyed the emperor but kines
defiantly says that her true master is
shai hulud which is the freman religious
name for the sand worms old father
eternity kines pounds the sand like a
thumper so that she and the sadaka are
eaten by her god
it's extremely badass and demonstrates
the power of the fremen and the sand
worms but in the book and in the old tv
mini-series kineza's death is very
different the harkenans leave kinds to
die in the desert he becomes delirious
and has hallucinations of his father
pardo padau lectures lietkinds about
their plan to change uracus with all
these endless scientific facts and
theories to control the environment but
while kynes thinks about controlling the
environment the environment is killing
him he's burning in the sun birds circle
above to eat him and in the end kynes is
killed by a spice blow which is the
explosive chemical reaction that creates
spice on arrakis so kynes and his father
spent their lives trying to master this
planet but kines gets killed by the
planet he tried to control
his knowledge and his science can't save
him
this shows the limits of human knowledge
and plans environmental forces the
complex ever-changing machinations of
the universe are bigger and more chaotic
than any person can control
no plan or science can tame the universe
nature always has the last word
paul and jessica escape by flying into a
storm arrakis dust storms are deadly
with winds that can cut metal like
butter and strip flesh to bone it should
be certain death but with paul's new
consciousness in the book he can
perceive the forces of the storm the
turbulence the vortexes all the tiny
gusts and fronts he feels all these
motions and sees the right path to fly
to safety
in the movie paul has a vision of this
fremen man james jammer says that to
understand a process you must flow with
it this is basically june's philosophy
of how to think the world is complicated
everything's interconnected and always
changing so you can't focus on just one
perspective or one set of data you can't
rely on one narrow plan like kines did
your thinking needs to continually
evolve with the changing flow of reality
and that's how paul and jessica survive
this storm by seeing and moving with its
flow
just as jessica and paul master their
fear by allowing it to flow through them
in the movie paul hears the voices of
bene jesuits telling him to let go and
so he lets go of the thopter controls
and he loses consciousness and somehow
survives it's like an act of faith in
the movie but the june book is not about
faith it's not about losing
consciousness it's about awareness and
choice and so that's how paul and
jessica survive
in the book
the harkinans think paul and jessica
died in the storm and that their victory
is finally complete so the baron puts
rabband back in charge of arrakis and he
tells him to squeeze to exploit and
oppress the people of arrakis to make as
much money as possible to make back the
money that they spent on their attack
the beast rabban is happy to be a brutal
dictator again in the book he
enthusiastically suggests exterminating
every person on arrakis and he asks
which weapons he's allowed to use on the
population the baron just orders rabban
to kill all the fremen in the book it's
the sardakar who do that but in the book
rabban says that it might not be easy to
kill the fremen in the book we see the
fremen kick the sadhakar's ass a couple
times and characters are shocked by how
deadly the fremen are but the baron
doesn't listen and arrogantly dismisses
the fremen as an irrelevant rabble
rabban is afraid of the baron the book
says that the baron usually won't kill
family members but he does inflict
painful punishments so rabban obeys
in the book there's a lot more going on
in the hearken plotline with other
important characters which we should see
in the next june movie
paul and jessica travel the desert
living off their own water in still
suits they begin a true arrokene
existence the rhythm of the environment
shapes their movements it changes when
they sleep and changes how they think
they get a feel for the textures of the
desert all the different kinds of sand
pea sand drum sand flower and grit and
dust and powder the desert looks like an
ocean full of moon-silvered waves
author frank herbert got the idea for
dune when he was researching sand dunes
in oregon he learned that dunes move and
flow like water just slower that began
his research into environments and
history and religion and linguistics
that led to dune
paul starts to like arrakis but jessica
just misses kaladan and misses lato
in the book jessica gets buried under a
sandslide so she uses her bene jesuit
training to hold her body in a coma so
she doesn't suffocate while paul uses
his powerful mind to figure out where
she's buried and saves her he does a
cute chemistry experiment mixing battery
acid with spice to make a foam to hold
back the sand it's a fun little science
fiction problem-solving scene using
paul's mind and simple tools to survive
to find the fremen paul and jessica have
to cross an expanse of open sand which
is super dangerous because of the deadly
worms sand worms swim these sands like
sharks in the sea but paul and jessica
face this danger just like the old duke
with the bull author frank herbert said
sand worms are like the bull in the
arena or like the archetypal dragon in
the cave guarding the treasure of spice
the worm is the monster that the hero
must face
to avoid attracting a worm they have to
walk without rhythm a sand walk that
imitates the natural sounds of the
desert in the book they also set a
thumper to distract the worms and it
turns out that it's very difficult to
walk without rhythm
while you can hear the rhythm of the
thumper it's yet another test of control
over the body and mind
paul accidentally steps on drum sand
which makes loud vibrations and it
summons a worm so they've got a legget
to the safety of a rock
paul and jessica are shocked by the size
of the sand worm in the book its mouth
is 80 meters or 260 feet across with
crystal teeth glimmering in the
moonlight and breath that smells like
cinnamon from the spice
paul wanders about the mystery of
exactly how spice and sandworms are
connected the book mentions that
sandworm's bodies create oxygen which is
how the air is breathable on arrakis
without many plants making oxygen like
on earth
but they survive the worm and then they
face stilger and his fremen and we start
to learn more about fremen culture in
the book stilgar asks if paul and
jessica are jinn which is an arabic word
for supernatural spirits stilgar
mentions istisla an islamic term
relating to the common good jessica
thinks that the fremen speak the
language of ilm and feek which are
arabic words for knowledge and law
because the fremen and their language
are loosely inspired by real arabic and
islamic cultures author frank herbert
was particularly influenced by a book
called the sabres of paradise about
muslims in the caucasus it describes a
religious warrior people who speak a
jacobse language and fight against
imperial pedesha invaders who live in a
siege or to beer there are entire lines
in dune that are taken from this book
frank was also inspired by lawrence of
arabia a western man who joined with
bedouin desert tribes in their fight
against the ottoman empire stilgar says
that the fremen are the ikwan bedouin
which sounds like bedouin
frank was also inspired by the people of
the kalahari desert and their careful
use of water so many different real
cultures inspired the fremen
in universe the june book says that the
fremen are descended from sunni muslims
in egypt mizir is arabic for egypt and
nilotic al-uraba suggests the nile and
arabia
over thousands of years this people's
religion changed into the zen sunni
tradition a combination of zen buddhism
with sunni islam
the zen sunni wanderers suffered
millennia of persecution and
displacement including nine generations
of slavery on seleucid secundus
eventually they settled on arrakis and
developed the unique fremen culture
adapted to life in the desert and
hardened by their suffering survival on
arrakis can require brutal decisions for
the good of the group so stilgaz fremen
threatened to kill jessica to take her
water so jessica uses her bene jesuit
fighting skills to kick stilgar's arse
and paul beats up the frerman man james
so jessica proves that she has useful
skills and stilgar agrees to keep her in
the book he has some fun dialogue
calling one of his men a worm-faced
crawling sand-brained piece of lizard
turd stilgar is charismatic and a
powerful leader dedicated to protecting
his tribe he's also very intelligent and
willing to adapt to change he asks
jessica to teach his friend how to fight
in her weirding way and the fremen will
teach jessica and paul how to survive in
the desert it will be a good exchange of
teachings june values knowledge and
learning
in the book jessica does more of her
missionary protactiva manipulations
trying to convince the fremen that she
and paul fit the lissan al-gaib prophecy
jessica brings up siege to beer
stilgar's home as though she has some
mystical knowledge of the place when
really she just read the name on a map
once
if only he knew the tricks we use she
thinks jessica feels a cynical
bitterness at her manipulation but she's
determined to use the fremen as an army
to help paul retake arrakis
paul meets cheney and he's shocked to
recognize her from his visions in the
books cheney has an elfin face a
laughing voice the grace of a gazelle
and she has red hair
paul feels embarrassed that she snuck up
on him with a gun and he immediately has
a crush on her
james is angry that paul beat him up so
james challenges paul invoking the amtal
rule amtal means to test something until
it breaks to learn someone's true nature
by pushing them to their limits like the
gomja bar test jammus will fight paul to
the death
in the book jamas says this will test
whether paul and jessica are really the
lizan al-gaib he argues that jessica
might be trying to make a false way
among us trying to deceive the fremen to
fit the prophecy which she is
in the book jessica uses the voice on
jammus and threatens him but the freeman
realizes she's manipulating him and
order her to be silent so paul faces
james alone
paul has seen possible futures from this
moment and in most of them paul dies
he is at the center of a nexus in time a
storm of possibilities where the
slightest mistake could change the
future dramatically there are too many
branching possibilities for paul to see
a clear path to victory the only way to
survive this is with his skills and his
mind and his knife
in the book cheney gives paul advice on
how to beat james warning him about
james's fighting style but in the movie
chaney says she doesn't believe in paul
and that he's gonna die which is a fun
change making cheney more skeptical of
paul
in the movie chaney gives paul a chris
knife and this is the same knife that
paul kept seeing in visions paul saw
cheney stabbing him with this knife will
this vision come true
paul salutes james in the same way that
duncan saluted earlier as a tribute to
his fallen friend and they prepare to
fight in the book paul and james fight
wearing just loincloths but in the movie
they wear their still suits so we don't
get to see timothy chalamet in just his
fighting trunks
in the movie paul hears the voices of
benny jesuit telling him not to be
afraid not to resist to fulfill his
destiny as the quizats had iraq but in
the book paul doesn't rely on destiny he
focuses on his training on the advice of
jessica duncan and gurney on his bene
jesuit mastery of his body and mind paul
is a fighting machine trained from
infancy by some of the best warriors in
the universe
but in the book paul's training gives
him a disadvantage cause paul is trained
for shield fighting he learned to attack
slowly so that his blade can penetrate
shields but james has no shield the
fremen don't use shields because shields
attract sand worms so paul keeps
attacking jammus too slowly while jameis
who isn't trained with shields attacks
faster than paul is used to so paul has
to change his fighting style sometimes
to survive you have to unlearn old
assumptions
so paul kills james winning the respect
of the freeman jessica is relieved that
her son survived but in the book she
does something interesting jessica
immediately comes up to paul and calls
him a killer her voice harsh and full of
scorn
jessica deliberately makes paul feel bad
about killing james because paul is a
young man getting a lot of attention and
validation for this victory including
from the literal girl of his dreams
cheney jessica doesn't want paul to
learn to enjoy killing so she applies
some emotional conditioning to keep
paul's morality in line
in the movie there's a real sadness to
james's death because earlier paul had
visions of james being a friend someone
who taught paul about the desert but
because of paul's choices and chance
that vision didn't come true and paul
had to kill the man who could have been
his friend
so paul's visions aren't guaranteed
they're only possibilities like plans
dreams hopes and fears in the real world
they can guide us to achieve our goals
but they can also blind us and limit our
thinking
june explores the power and the danger
of predictions and dreams
in the book paul cries for james and the
fremen see crying as a profound sacred
act because of how precious water is in
the desert paul says that james was his
friend that james taught him that
killing has a price
so maybe in a way paul's vision of james
as a friend who taught him did come true
after all
the fremen wrap up james's body and take
it with them because when a freman dies
the water is drained from their body in
a death still and reclaimed for the
fremen to use
the flesh belongs to the person but his
water belongs to the tribe
in the movie paul gives a confident
heroic speech he says he sees the future
and that he chooses to be with the
fremen but at this point in the book the
vibe is darker and uncertain paul and
jessica are unsure about the freeman but
feel forced to use them to survive paul
doesn't see his future clearly he feels
he is plunged into the abyss he's afraid
of his visions of the bloody jihad and
desperately hopes to prevent it paul's
destiny is dangerous
we see a freeman riding a sand worm to
travel we have much more to learn about
the power of the fremen and their desert
cheyney says this is only the beginning
and it really is
this june movie only covers the first
half of the first book in the dune
trilogy which itself is just the
beginning of a larger series there is so
much more to this story
frank herbert said that the first june
book has a coital rhythm meaning the
pacing of the story is like sex it
starts slow and speeds up and then
suddenly climactically ends
so by ending this movie halfway through
the first book denny villeneuve stops
mid coitus leaving us waiting without a
climax until june part 2 comes out
this movie is a mostly faithful
adaptation of the first half of the
first book it introduces the worlds and
politics of the imperium the mysterious
spacing guild the scheming bene jesuit
the evil harkenans defeat the atreides
paul and jessica escape to the fremen
and they start to learn the ways of the
desert we see paul's complicated destiny
and ambiguous visions with hints of the
dangers of the messiah
the movie introduces ideas of the
environment and religion and political
exploitation and the power of the mind
but the movie leaves out some important
scenes like the dinner party and the
traitor subplot it doesn't capture the
tragedy of dr yui the meaning of kain's
death or the darker manipulative side of
lato and jessica it removes some of the
arabic references from the fremen and it
skips some plotlines with the
hearkenance and with thufia hopefully
we'll get this in the next june movie
but to understand the meaning of paul's
story and the message of dune we've got
to talk about the other books in the
series so we've got another video called
the philosophy of june coming out soon
we've also got a podcast episode out now
talking about tune with quinn from
quinn's ideas we're also doing a q a
live stream about dune on this channel
in 24 hours and for some reason
professional [ __ ] poster alt swift x has
released a rap about june so go check
out all that gian content linked below
we're going to make more dune videos in
the future we're also covering more song
of ice and fire and the upcoming game of
thrones prequel tv show house of the
dragon house of the dragon is based on a
book called fire and blood you can get
fire and blood or dune as an audio book
for free right now at audible.com asx
sign up for a premium plus trial
membership and you can get an audiobook
to keep even if you cancel the trial you
could get any game of thrones or dune or
expanse audiobook membership also
includes unlimited access to thousands
of audiobooks and shows in the audible
plus catalog sign up at audible.com asx
or text asx to 500 500 and make sure you
choose the premium plus trial membership
for the free audiobook
thank you to the artists and essays
linked below and thanks to the patrons
including kevin wharton trish ledoux the
360 archangel stan tor paul luke master
a steve norum annie claire and joe snow
cheers
like and subscribe to alt shift x